I really hope you people appreciate what
I do for you cuz let me tell you it's
not always easy the stupid ass shit I
gotta sit through is just well it's not
always fun I mean a bad movie is one
thing that's like two hours but to watch
episode upon episode of manufactured
pleasure shit or plush shit as I like to
call it quite often is just more than I
can bear the only upside I never thought
to share my misery when that people who
requested it in the first place with
that said full house for those who you
blessed without the knowledge of the
show I'll fill you full house grant in
the late 80s and early 90s on ABC's
Friday lineup TGIF which usually had
about four family-friendly sitcoms that
always got called back toward depressing
reality by ending with 20/20
thank you you devil full house often
start off the lineup with its cutesy
wutesy non-threatening as well as not
funny humor and actually ended up
lasting for eight seasons eight seasons
that is shit
I can't last eight minutes watching this
try how the hell did they last eight
seasons I mean it's a genuine mystery
nobody liked this show so how the hell
did it do so well well let's swallow our
dignity and try to find out so we get a
typical mid eighties opening where
people at the time just love to fold
their arms laugh and smile hoping points
identity their credits will fear under
them while gender-confused doo-wop band
sings about the force of life
those days especially love this image of
a cutesy scenario going out while we
stare at a gigantic prison
that's not symbolic I don't know what so
what's the story you're pleading me not
to tell you well the world's raunchiest
family icon Bob Saget plays a character
named dam who just lost his wife to the
always horrible insert name here
deceased he lives in San Francisco with
his three daughters DJ Stephanie and
Michelle played by the pair of twins
often mistaken for talented mary-kate
and Ashley Olsen but raising three girls
is tough so Dan calls upon a guitar
player who's not cool and a comedian
who's not funny
the Mullen memos here are known as Jesse
played by John Stamos is also a
brother-in-law and Joey played by Dave
Coulier and if you think there's
anything odd about three prissy guys
living in a house with no women you've
clearly never been to San Francisco so
how bad is this show well let's take a
look at the very first joke of a very
first episode of running the babies
sleeping like a baby
and it's all downhill from there I mean
I've watched several episodes and not
one of these jokes made me laugh not one
I didn't even get one the sheer
stupidity on it it's a bit like
statistically impossible
I should have laughed at least once but
talking about it doesn't help let's take
a closer look at these characters Jessi
for example it's a tough guy well as
tough as a pile of Fonzie Sammy downs
can look let's play ballerina why do you
play ballerina
I knew tippy toes tippy toes right this
was written people Joey is a silly
comedian always making wisecracks and
punchline that quite frankly make you
want to castrate yourself huh good good
good good good good you know the guy
from the police academy movies the one
that did all the incredible sound
effects Dave Coulier is nothing like
that guy hi Michelle it's me Kermit the
Frog hi it's me pee-wee Herman huh do
you want to go to my place is life a man
of a thousand and one impressions and
not one of them right move back into the
house you can have a big juicy Bowl
jello ma I figure I imitate a funny
successful comedian I myself may one day
become one oh and did I mention he has a
puppet of which a brilliantly named mr.
woodchuck and be nice to hold something
warm and cuddly that didn't always talk
about wood I'm above that joke then you
got Dan his gimmick I guess is that he's
just clean okay so the first thing you
do when you get to the dance look at all
the fire exits keep your eye on your
coat the entire night if the punch
smells funny don't drink it
oh he's a little Chrissy - okay let's
face it I'm a lean mean hugging machine
okay he's a lot prissy in fact knowing
about saying it the way we know him now
this is actually really funny to watch
anyone who watches Bob Saget stand-up
knows that he is a raunchy raunchy man
and you know that saying all this
family-friendly bullshit is probably
just killing him in fact let's compare
Dan Tanner and Bob Saget for a second
shall we I know exactly how you feel
and I know how much you girls miss your
mother I banged half the girls in the
room and that is fucking not true I have
not banged anyone here I stuck my pinky
in your butt's couple of you she was
devastated and broke my heart to see the
tears in her eyes
fuck that shit no thanks I'm good do not
kids don't fuck that shit you're getting
infection you listen to me
dantana blow oh my number one then you
got DJ's who I have to admit as she got
older did get consistently hotter but
that didn't change the fact that she had
little to no personality wow you have a
date and a dress so for my problems
looking like a bag of chips and remote
control life is hell there's Stephanie
also but she's sort of on the same phone
of blandest neither characters really
make an effort to stand out
Stephanie what are you doing just
hanging around God and then of course
there's the gremlin babies themselves
the Olsen twins as Michelle who I think
literally just had the job of spewing
catchphrases what'll it be comic kibbles
or bits you're going down supposed to
keep your cards close to your body
you're opposed to keep your eyes close
to your head
ah I guess this was the character who
stole the show or would if there's
anything of value to steal some reason
the Olsen twins really took off and made
a video series that literally transform
them into millionaires that's where it
also transformed them into Barbie dolls
but to be fair I think the dolls are a
little less plastic you look just like
Sleeping Beauty except you're awake the
cash cow goes hmm but when it started
out they were just exploitable babies
and the studio took advantage of every
friggin frame they were in for example
one episode was about changing a diaper
ooh Oh take the south mmm good
thank God and applause people that gives
you an idea that kind of humor they deal
with on here but that's not the only
pressing issue this show addresses
there's a lot of other gut wrenching
dilemmas that this show dares to
challenge like who's going to do the
dishes is the hammock gonna be put up
okay and of course who can limbo the
lowest let's get ready to limb but
that's not all
here's a list of some of the other
episodes to give you an idea about how
truly exciting this show was the first
day of school the return of Grandma sea
cruise and daddy's home
you know what this is this is the life
of people in picture frames no issues no
real dilemmas just a series of cuddly
inconveniences this family makes Norman
Rockwell look butch was involved well
yeah there's other characters who
eventually evolved into the show like
Becky fell in love with Jesse and
eventually married him again she's
pretty dull but I'd be lying if I didn't
say she was kind of high we're doing the
balcony scene from Romeo and Juliet yeah
I did that play in junior high wasn't a
lot of fun though well I went to an
all-girls school in fact I was Romeo
rather than oh I don't know move out of
the house Jesse and Becky stay together
and give birth to twin boys yeah because
one set of annoying bad acting twins
just wasn't enough in Oasis know this
keep Noddy
these boys are no actors as you can
clearly see you can finally see the cue
cards the rating off you're no fun
anymore
there's also DJ's Frank Kimmy the white
female circle of the group I'm
practicing her bagpipes for der Scottish
Music Festival after school
you know every time a Joe from Full
House is uttered a poor soul commits
suicide don't get your kilt in a knot
McGreevy you see there's also DJ's
boyfriend Steve whose voice you may
actually recognize know exactly how you
felt like someone punched you in the
stomach and knocked all the wind daddy
perfect timing a move as usual that's
right it's Aladdin from well Aladdin
that's an interesting bit of trivia for
you but what the hell is he doing on
this show I recently caught up with the
actor who played this role that asked
him why he took a part in such a
god-awful show he had this to say got to
live guy still to eat tell you all about
it when I got that time yeah it's from
our talk we will we flew him into
Chicago to do an audio interview and he
chose to answer everything and so on
he's quite quirky that way oh and
there's also a dog named comet because
this show just wasn't cute enough yet
all the missing is a little fairy name
pretty pretty fun head and this atom
bomb of cuteness will be complete set
your adorable levels to 10 now most
shows often have a theme or pattern but
in full house case it's more of an
overused manipulative plot device and
trust me when I say they have several
like how about the corny music that
we'll play whenever our speech is being
made what is it honey
it's just not fair and even know what
love was until I met you
where's my mom how out of it was I
we were here sweetheart I was like are
you this person it's not like the actual
emotion of the scene is enough to carry
it so we have to place shitty-ass music
to let you know when to feel something
God what I wouldn't give to give that
sandy ass music over a scene that didn't
require it Stephanie
there's a time in every girl's life when
she might be noticing some changes they
might seem strange or bizarre to you but
it happens to every young Clinton it's
called having a period it's gross
disgusting and unnatural but it's
something that all females go through
you may see your body as something
possessed horrifying or despicable and
that's because it is stop it right now
but that's not the only pattern every
single show has a relatively harmless
problem that always seems to be solved
within a half-hour time later more in
most cases a one-minute speech but you
still got me
he got me too and me and me and me and
me and me
I'll move back in oh yes you'll often
find that the studio audience for the
show is very easy to impress for example
here's what happens every time somebody
kisses me they like each other
oh I better to make kiss the holding
hand so we all know how the show begins
but if you're like me you're wondering
how the hell does it all end well
unfortunately a killing spree isn't
involved however while the characters
does get injured
Michelle is involved in a horse racing
competition as it turns out Dan and
another girl's mother give way into
their daughter's achievements could you
come out my little girls I'm a parent
not a groomer oh I'm sorry
you just had the air of stable health
excuse me I'm snobby fawn persnickety
bitch I don't know if you saw Michelle
riding out there but if she entered the
competition she could win enjoy your
little fantasy because in reality my
Elizabeth wins this competition every
year actually eat good for breakfast and
regurgitate it as evil delightful
practice this is why you don't go to
public school yeah these scenes are so
bad even the horse looks like he's
suffering family wishes you could talk
back to happen these morons you know
what I think maybe it missed a spot
let me please this is so demeaning I
wish I was blue what do you think
Peppermill you like the idea just stand
there you're an insipid twat
he loves it all right pepper mill I am
gonna tell you the same thing my beloved
track coach told me right before my very
first big track meet tanner you keep
those water bottles filled your humor is
like my balls old and non-functioning
well that's going on Jesse and Joe we
tried to put together a show about how
they're going to go in to wrestle okay
what mental asylum did this a won't
break out of put my foot around your
neck like
this
this was a family show right
so Michelle the other girl decide to go
out and practice when suddenly tragedy
strikes Goldfinch who are you what else
maybe I could be a stand-in on
Seabiscuit oh my gosh what happened
should I do my Popeye impression
so Michelle wakes up but unfortunately
has a horrible case of amnesia actually
what am I talking about it's not
unfortunate at all I wish I had that
right now well memory loss is very
common with head injuries how long it's
gonna last
well usually it's just temporary one
episode 20 minutes tops
so everyone tries to get Michelle to
remember who she is Dan Jessi joke
seriously dude which hospital
so do you all live in the neighborhood
no you're gonna love this we all live in
this house oh I hope it's bigger than it
looks from the outside well through the
magic of studio set splat holes and
inconsistent writing yeah so her memory
does finally return in a weird
existential moment where the two sisters
are finally shown on-screen together I'm
remembering what the heck have you been
I've been looking all over for you
I hope I didn't cause you any trouble
duh psychology for dummies by dummies
gee I sure hope there's an over winded
speech with shitty music to close us out
but you stuck it out and got true
just like we always do
just like we always will
this show is the worst it's like if a
Hallmark card pissed all of your family
album and then somehow mutated into a
sitcom
it was another funny never clever never
endearing so why do we keep watching it
eight seasons hello that's a long time
to watch untalented acts centered around
a pair of unfunny female troll goblins
it's almost as if they were sending a
subliminal messages or something in fact
what happens if you play the Olsen twins
dialogue backwards you look just like
sleeping TD it work it watch your shows
and Merkel's money oh my god and I
wasn't seen there what manufacture oh my
god the Olsen twins are mutant alien
robots bent on world domination I know
it all along crebbil the people have to
know
Oh
come play with us critic or come please
come play with us critic and
I did it
they're dead you believe them trying to
take over the world of course of course
well seeing how they are in fact dead I
will just turn around and go to my
normal duties because you know they're
dead it's not like they're gonna pop up
anywhere and where else especially on my
way back to the room so I'm just gonna
make that turn I told you about a second
ago and here I go you see nothing there
huh so I'll just get back to work
oh it was just a dream all along well
I'm a Nostalgia Critic I remember I'm in
this - okay you know what I do and you
know why I do it